>> PREVIOUSLY ON AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL
>> THE GIRLS LET GO OF
SOME EMOTIONAL BAGGAGE...
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT I WANT!
THAT'S THE POINT.
>> THEN PACKED THEIR BAGS
FOR A TRIP TO SPAIN...
>> WHOO!
>> AAH!
>> MASTERING THE NATIVE TONGUE
WAS DIFFICULT...
>> (speaks Catalan haltingly)
>> BUT JAEDA'S TROUBLES ON SET
SPILLED OVER
TO THE JUDGING ROOM...
JAEDA, YOU LOOK NERVOUS.
>> I... BLEW THIS, MAN.
>> AND SHE WAS SENT HOME.
FIVE GIRLS REMAIN--
MELROSE, EUGENA, MICHELLE,
CARIDEE AND AMANDA.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
DO YOU WANT TO BE ON TOP?
♪ ♪ ♪
>> OH, HOUSE.
I'M SO THANKFUL TO BE IN YOU.
WHEN I'M WALKING DOWN WITH JAEDA
AND I'M HOLDING HER HAND,
THERE'S A PART OF ME
THAT THINKS I'M GOING HOME.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME THERE'S
A STRONGER PART OF ME SAYING
IT'S NOT MY TIME TO GO YET.
>> THIS IS A REALLY BIG
LEARNING EXPERIENCE FOR ME.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT I WANT
OUT OF LIFE.
MAYBE IT'S MODELING.
MAYBE IT'S NOT.
>> I REALLY WANT THIS,
AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT ELSE
I WANT IN LIFE.
WHEN TYRA PULLS MY PHOTO OUT...
>> I THINK YOU CAN DELIVER
A COMMERCIAL, CARIDEE.
>> IT FELT GOOD,
BECAUSE I'VE WORKED MY ASS OFF
IN THIS COMPETITION.
I WANT TO GET OUT OF THE HOUSE.
>> I SAY WE CALL LUCAS.
(cell phone rings)
>> WE CALLED UP THE GUYS
WHO WE HAD THE PHOTO SHOOT
WITH BEFORE THAT DID
A COMMERCIAL WITH US.
(speaks Catalan)
>> Hola?
>> LUCAS?
>> Yes?
>> WE WERE WONDERING
IF YOU WOULD ACCOMPANY US
TO DINNER TONIGHT.
WHEN I GO TO DIFFERENT
COUNTRIES,
I WANNA GO HAVE A NICE DINNER
AND A GLASS OF WINE...
OR FOUR.
CAN YOU BRING SOME FRIENDS
AND COME AND MEET US?
>> Yeah. What time?
>> OKAY. WE'LL SEE YOU
AT, LIKE, 8:00.
>> (laughs)
>> All right.
>> 'KAY. BYE, SEXY.
>> OOH!
>> THIS IS LIKE--AAH!
>> HEY! HI!
>> SPANISH GUYS AND
AMERICAN GUYS
ARE VERY SIMILAR.
THEY ALL HAVE THE SAME JOKES
AND STUFF,
BUT SPANISH GUYS SMELL BETTER.
>> TO NEW FRIENDS, NEW PLACES
AND NEW EXPERIENCES.
>> YEAH, WE'LL PLAY GAMES.
>> WHAT HAPPENS IN SPAIN
STAYS IN SPAIN.
>> (laughs)
>> CARIDEE AND VICTOR
WENT OUT TO HAVE A CHAT,
AND I-I KIND OF WANT TO KNOW
HOW THEIR CONVERSATION WENT,
'CAUSE NEITHER OF THEM SPEAKS
THE SAME LANGUAGE AT ALL.
>> CARIDEE...
SHE'S ALL OVER THE PLACE.
I DON'T THINK SHE KNOWS
HOW TO STOP.
>> IT'S NOT A COMPETITION
RIGHT NOW.
IT IS JUST ABOUT HAVING FUN
AND BEING IN SPAIN
AND HAVING AMAZING EXPERIENCES.
(whispers) GO. GO. BYE.
ADIOS.
>> AT FIRST, I DIDN'T--
I HAD NO IDEA WHAT WE WERE
DOING.
WE WERE JUST GETTING READY
FOR SOME SORT OF SURPRISE THING.
>> HEY!
>> HEY.
>> WHAT'S UP?
HOW ARE Y'ALL DOING?
ARE YOU DOING GOOD?
>> YES.
>> YEAH?
WHAT I WANT TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT
IS THE HARSH REALITIES
OF THE MODELING INDUSTRY,
'CAUSE THIS INDUSTRY IS PROBABLY
ONE OF THE MOST DIFFICULT
INDUSTRIES THERE IS,
BECAUSE IT IS VERY DIFFICULT
TO IMPROVE ON YOUR PRODUCT.
IF YOU'RE AN ACTOR,
YOU CAN GO TO AN ACTING COACH
AND TRY TO GET BETTER.
IF YOU'RE A SINGER,
AND THEY'RE LIKE,
"OOH, YOU KIND OF SING
OFF-KEY SOMETIMES,"
YOU CAN GO TO A SINGING COACH
AND KIND OF GET BETTER.
IF YOU'RE IN THE MODELING WORLD,
AND THEY'RE LIKE,
"WE JUST DON'T LIKE YOUR LOOK"--
YOU CAN KIND OF CUT YOUR HAIR,
BUT YOU'RE STILL YOU.
AND WHAT I WANT
TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT IS WHAT
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL" IS.
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
IS THAT COACH TO GET YOU
AS STRONG AS YOU CAN
TO GET INTO THAT INDUSTRY,
AND I-I WANT TO START
BY ASKING YOU ALL ABOUT
CRITIQUE.
WHAT IS THE HARSHEST THING
THAT YOU HAVE HEARD
IN THE JUDGING ROOM SINCE YOU'VE
BEEN IN THIS COMPETITION?
>> PROBABLY THAT I LOOK LIKE
A 4-YEAR-OLD, UM, WALKING--
WALKING IN MY MOTHER'S HEELS.
>> (laughs)
>> I THOUGHT THAT ONE
WAS PRETTY HARSH.
>> OKAY, TRY TO WALK WITH
SOME POISE. GET IT TOGETHER.
GET IT TOGETHER.
WELL, WHY WAS THAT ONE
HARSH FOR YOU?
>> PEOPLE SAY, "OH, YEAH.
YOU'RE BAD. YOU'RE BAD."
AND THAT WAS JUST LIKE,
WOW. REALLY? THAT BAD?
>> WHO ELSE?
>> WELL, I THINK JUST LAST WEEK
WAS A REALLY--BLOW FOR ME.
>> SWEETHEART, YOU ALMOST LOOK
DRUNK IN THAT.
YOU LOOKED A LITTLE CRAZY TO ME.
IT WAS LIKE A TRAIN WRECK.
>> I WANT TO REPRESENT
"A.N.T.M."
AND ALL YOU JUDGES JUST, LIKE,
IN A VERY RESPECTFUL, GOOD WAY,
AND I DON'T WANT TO BE
MISUNDERSTOOD--
>> AT THE FIRST PANEL--
THAT I PHOTOGRAPH OLD.
I MEAN, THAT WAS THE
WORST PANEL FOR ME.
>> WHAT WORRIES ME IN A
SHOT LIKE THIS IS THAT
YOU PHOTOGRAPH LOOKING OLD.
AND, YOU KNOW,
THAT'S WITH RETOUCHING.
>> THAT WAS, LIKE, A DAGGER.
>> UM, SINCE I'VE BEEN RIPPED TO
SHREDS BY PANEL...
>> (laughs)
>> I'M KIND OF IMMUNE TO IT,
BUT THEN WHEN YOU SAID THAT
YOU WERE DISAPPOINTED IN ME--
IT'S LIKE, YOU DON'T WANT TO BE
A DISAPPOINTMENT, YOU KNOW?
>> MM-HMM.
>> YOU PICKED US AND YOU HAD
SUCH HIGH HOPES FOR US,
AND THEN WE GET HERE,
AND IT JUST SEEMS LIKE
WE'RE THROWING IT ALL AWAY.
AND THAT'S VERY DISAPPOINTING
TO MYSELF.
>> MR. JAY, HE COMMENTED
THAT, UH,
HE WASN'T SURE IF I SHOULD BE
IN THIS COMPETITION ANYMORE.
AND JUST TO HEAR SOMEONE SAY
I SHOULDN'T BE IN IT AT ALL,
THAT WAS JUST HARD TO HEAR.
'CAUSE IT'S LIKE,
WOW, THAT'S REALLY HARSH.
>> SO AFTER THIS COMPETITION,
I WANT YOU TO BE STRONG ENOUGH
AND LIFT YOUR HEAD UP HIGH
AND BE ABLE TO HANDLE
ANYTHING AND EVERYTHING
THAT COMES YOUR WAY.
I WANT YOU TO SPEAK WELL.
I WANT YOU TO LOOK GREAT.
I WANT YOU TO BE INTELLIGENT.
I WANT YOU TO KNOW THIS
INDUSTRY.
AND IF I HAVE TO SAY THINGS
THAT MAKE YOU HATE ME
AND MAKE YOUR FANS HATE ME,
SO BE IT.
I'M GONNA SACRIFICE MYSELF
FOR YOU.
OKAY? ALL RIGHT.
GIMME A HUG, EVERYBODY.
ALL RIGHT. SO YOU JUST KNOW,
THAT'S--THAT'S WHAT IT IS.
AND IT'S HARSH, AND IT'S STRONG,
AND I'M GONNA SEE YOU
IN JUDGING VERY SOON.
>> (laughs) YES.
>> AND I'M GOING TO BE THAT.
IT'S COMING FROM A PLACE OF LOVE
AND A PLACE OF MAMA.
IT'S MAMA. IT'S THE COACH.
AND THE ONE THING THAT'S
IMPORTANT TO KNOW IS
WHEN YOU'RE GETTING COACHED
AND TRAINED WITH SOMETHING,
IT'S THE WORST FEELING
IN THE WORLD.
AND YOU REJECT IT,
AND YOU'RE LIKE, "UGH."
BUT THEN WHEN YOU'RE IN THE
JUNGLE,
AND THE THINGS ARE HAPPENING
THAT THAT COACH SAID,
YOU'RE LIKE, "DANG. OH, MY GOSH.
IT'S COMING TRUE."
ONE DAY IT'S GONNA HIT YOU,
AND YOU'LL BE LIKE,
"DANG. TYRA SAID THAT."
ALL RIGHT. SO I'LL SEE
YOU GUYS LATER, OKAY?
>> OKAY.
>> OKAY. BYE.
>> THANK YOU.
♪ ♪ ♪
>> TYRA MAIL.
>> "ONLY THE ELITE WILL CONTINUE
ON IN THE COMPETITION.
GET READY TO SEE WHO WILL
GO AND WHO WILL STAY.
LOVE, TYRA."
>> AY, YI, YI.
>> OH, Sí.
>> HELLO, LADIES.
WELCOME TO ELITE SPAIN.
MY NAME IS PANCHO SAULA.
I AM THE DIRECTOR OF THIS
AGENCY.
>> I THINK THIS IS THE
CHALLENGE THAT
WE ALL NEED TO BE ON OUR TOES,
BECAUSE THE PRIZE
FOR WINNING THIS COMPETITION
IS A CONTRACT WITH ELITE.
>> I'VE ORGANIZED ABOUT TEN
DESIGNERS TO SEE YOU,
TO MEET YOU--A GO SEE.
THE IMPORTANT THING ABOUT
THE GO SEE IS THAT YOU REALLY
HAVE TO IMPRESS THE PEOPLE
THAT YOU'RE GONNA MEET TODAY.
EACH DESIGNER WILL EVALUATE YOU
ON THEIR POINT SYSTEM,
DEPENDING ON YOUR PERSONAL
APPEARANCE, YOUR RUNWAY WALK,
YOUR PERSONALITY,
YOUR PORTFOLIOS.
THE MORE DESIGNERS YOU SEE,
THE MORE CHANCES
YOU'LL HAVE TO LAND THE JOB.
THE SPANISH CLIENTS LOVE
MODELS THAT SMILE
AND THAT HAVE LOTS OF ENERGY.
AND YOU HAVE TO BE BACK
IN THE AGENCY AT 6:00 P.M.
DON'T BE LATE.
AND I HAVE READY FOR YOU
THE MODEL PORTFOLIOS.
>> (claps) YAY!
>> AND I'LL BE GIVING YOU,
AS WELL, THE MAP OF BARCELONA.
SO GOOD LUCK.
>> YOU HAVE TO BE BACK
TO THE AGENCY BY 6:00 P.M.
AND THAT IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT RULE.
>> WHOO!
>> OKAY.
>> I'M WEARING HEELS.
I'M NERVOUS.
THE MAPS ARE IN SPANISH.
I HAD A FEELING I WAS IN
FOR A HARD TIME.
WHERE ARE YOU GOING?
>> I'M GOING TO THIS ONE
RIGHT HERE.
INITIALLY, I WAS GONNA
GO BY MYSELF,
BUT THEN, I DIDN'T WANT
TO GET LOST,
AND THEN CARIDEE WANTED US
TO GO TOGETHER.
ONE OF US SHOULD GO HERE,
ONE OF US SHOULD GO THERE,
AND THEN MEET BACK HERE.
>> DO YOU LIKE THE IDEA
OF GOING FAR FIRST AND GETTING
ALL THESE FIVE OUT OF THE WAY?
>> ME AND AMANDA KIND OF
JUST NATURALLY TEAMED UP.
WE JUST LOOKED OVER AT EACH
OTHER, AND WE'RE LIKE,
"HEY, WE'RE GOING TOGETHER."
DO ANY OF YOU SPEAK ENGLISH?
>> MY STRATEGY IS JUST TO
GO BY MYSELF
AND TO HAVE A GREAT DAY OF
GETTING AWAY FROM THESE GIRLS.
HOLA!
>> WELCOME TO SITA MURT.
>> I WENT TO SCHOOL FOR
FASHION DESIGN.
>> SHE MOVED ALL RIGHT.
AND SHE LISTEN TO ME,
SO WHEN I TOLD HER
THAT SHE--SHE SHOULD CHANGE
THE WAY OF WALKING, SHE DID
THAT.
>> OKAY,
SO I THINK WE'RE SUPPOSED
TO BE GOING THAT WAY.
>> DESIGNERS LIKE HAPPY MODELS,
SO YOU SMILE AS MUCH AS YOU CAN
AND DO YOUR WALK, AND THAT'S IT.
I THINK IT WENT WELL.
>> THANK YOU.
I THINK THAT EUGENA EH, HAS
MORE POSSIBILITIES
IN THIS PROFESSION.
>> AAH!
SORRY IF I'M OUT OF BREATH.
I WAS JUST...
I'M--I WAS SO LOST.
>> WHERE DO YOU COME FROM?
>> UM, NORTH DAKOTA.
I'M DEFINITELY GOING
FOR QUALITY AND IMPRESSING
AND JUST BEING MYSELF.
>> WE DON'T NEED THIS.
>> OH, I'M SORRY.
>> AND WE DON'T NEED THIS.
>> OKAY.
>> WELL, THIS IS A MISTAKE,
TO WEAR ANY NECKLACE
OR ANYTHING.
SHE MUST FEEL THAT SHE
IS LIKE A CANVAS.
>> OKAY, THIS--
SO WE TURN THIS WAY, RIGHT?
EVERYTHING ELSE IS ON THAT
SIDE OF THE STREET.
>> NO, WE'RE AT THIS ONE,
STUPID!
>> HOLA. OOH!
THIS IS LIKE MY DREAM SHOP.
I WENT TO SCHOOL TO DESIGN
CLOTHES.
>> MELROSE-- HER PERSONALITY,
IT'S REALLY NICE.
>> WHO'S THE MODEL? BOTH OF YOU?
>> BOTH OF US.
>> Sí. I'M CARIDEE.
I HOPE I IMPRESS THE SPANISH
DESIGNERS.
I WAS JUST BEING MYSELF.
AND BEING MYSELF CAN GET ME FAR,
OR IT CAN PUT THE FOOT IN MY
MOUTH.
DO I GET TO KEEP IT?
>> NO, SORRY.
>> (laughs) JUST JOKING.
>> HOLA. HERE'S MY BOOK.
>> WOW.
>> I LOVE FASHION--
EVERYTHING ABOUT IT.
>> I LOVED EUGENA.
SHE LOOKED VERY, VERY GOOD.
SHE'S A BIT SERIOUS, THOUGH.
>> DO YOU WANT TO GO BACK?
WHAT THE HELL DO YOU WANT TO DO?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I WANT TO LEAVE YOU SOMETIMES.
>> THEN LEAVE ME. I DON'T CARE.
>> MICHELLE AND I ARE
REALLY CONFUSED.
WE CAN'T FIND STREET SIGNS,
AND WE DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO.
>> I DIDN'T NEED A LITTLE
COUNTERPART-BUDDY.
I DID IT ALL BY MY DAMN SELF.
I BETTER WIN, 'CAUSE I WORKED
MY ASS OFF TODAY.
♪ ♪ ♪
>> DID YOU GO TO HIM ALREADY?
>> NO, I'M GOING RIGHT NOW.
>> CROSS FASTER!
>> OKAY. GOD. LET'S RUN THEN.
>> WE HAVE TO GO TO TEN GO SEES,
AND IT'S SPREAD OUT
ALL THROUGHOUT BARCELONA.
>> OKAY, ADDRESS...
GO SEES ARE, LIKE,
A CASTING FOR A JOB.
DEFINITELY WANT TO GET
AS MANY AS I CAN,
BECAUSE IT'S A POINT SYSTEM,
AND CLEARLY,
THE MORE THAT YOU GET,
THE BETTER YOU'RE GONNA DO
IN THIS CHALLENGE.
>> WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
STREET SIGNS LOOK LIKE HERE.
I'M BAD WITH DIRECTIONS.
I COULDN'T EVEN GET AROUND
ANAHEIM VERY WELL,
AND I LIVED THERE ALL MY LIFE.
>> RIGHT HERE, IN THERE.
THIS IS IT.
>> IT TOOK ME AND MY SISTER
AN HOUR TO GET
TO OUR FIRST LOCATION.
>> COME ON, LET ME SEE YOU.
PUT YOUR HAIR DOWN.
SMILE A LOT.
I DO FEEL A LITTLE COMPETITION
WITH MY SISTER,
JUST 'CAUSE WE LOOK THE SAME.
BUT I ALSO WANT HER TO DO GOOD.
>> YOU ALWAYS THIS THIN?
>> YES, I'VE ALWAYS BEEN THIS
THIN.
I'VE ALWAYS BEEN, LIKE,
A TOMBOY.
I'VE NEVER HAD, LIKE, THIS DREAM
OF ALWAYS BEING A MODEL.
I WANT IT, BUT, LIKE,
I DON'T KNOW IF I HAVE IT.
>> I DON'T LIKE HOW SHE WALKS.
I THINK MICHELLE--
I COULD USE HER AS MY CATALOG
MODEL,
NOT AS, YOU KNOW, RUNWAY MODEL.
>> SIT DOWN HERE?
>> CARIDEE AND I ENDED UP
STICKING TOGETHER.
THAT WAS OUR ORIGINAL PLAN.
>> PERFECTO.
>> GRACIAS.
I THINK I DID GOOD.
I WALKED ABOUT A MILLION TIMES.
I KIND OF LOOKED LIKE A
KILLER TOMATO,
BUT, YOU KNOW, IT WAS FUN.
>> (laugh)
>> THE BEST PART OF MY STRATEGY
FOR THIS CHALLENGE
WAS TO NOT HAVE A PARTNER,
'CAUSE, WHEN IT COMES DOWN TO
IT,
WE'RE ALL IN THIS COMPETITION
ALONE.
>> HERE'S YOUR MAP AND
YOUR THING.
I'M GOING IN.
MY SISTER AND I PLANNED
TO STAY TOGETHER UNTIL WE WENT
BACK TO THE CLOSER LOCATIONS.
BUT THAT DIDN'T REALLY WORK,
'CAUSE WE WERE RUNNING OUT OF
TIME.
>> WITH AMANDA, I WAS AMAZED,
BECAUSE BEING A TWIN SISTER,
THEY'RE TOTALLY DIFFERENT.
SHE'S MUCH BETTER THAN HER
SISTER, HUH?
>> HOLA.
>> HEY.
>> HOW ARE YOU DOING?
>> UH, OKAY.
HOW MANY PEOPLE HAVE YOU SEEN?
>> THIS IS MY FIFTH.
>> YOUR FIFTH?
>> I NEED TO HURRY UP,
BECAUSE THE TWINS
ARE ON MY ASS NOW,
AND I GOTTA GO.
>> WHERE THE HELL AM I?
>> WE'RE RUNNING AWAY
FROM THE PAPARAZZI. (laughs)
>> I JUST DON'T WANT
MELROSE TO WIN.
SHE'S REALLY FAKE,
SHE DOESN'T LIKE US
AND SHE THINKS SHE'S BETTER
THAN EVERYBODY.
>> THE LAST GUY, I TOTALLY
SUCKED AT, BECAUSE I WAS WORRIED
ABOUT THE TIME AND GETTING BACK,
SO I WAS, LIKE, RUSHING LIKE
CRAZY.
>> I'M NOT WORRIED ABOUT
MELROSE.
>> CAN YOU TAKE ME HERE?
>> CAN I GET A RECEIPT?
ADIOS.
>> (sighs) MI CASA ES SU CASA.
>> WELCOME BACK.
YOU'VE MADE IT BEFORE 6:00.
>> CARIDEE AND I GOT BACK
ACTUALLY AT THE SAME TIME
AS MELROSE DID.
AND THEN THE TWINS WEREN'T
THERE.
>> HEY, GIRL.
>> TWINSY. LATE, I'M GUESSING?
>> WELCOME BACK.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY,
YOU HAVE ARRIVED LATE,
SO YOU ARE DISQUALIFIED
OF THIS CHALLENGE.
I WILL ASK YOU TO LEAVE.
>> BYE.
>> WHERE'S AMANDA?
IT'S BEEN A HALF-HOUR.
IS SHE LOST IN SPAIN?
>> Sí.
>> YOU ARE LATE.
>> I'M LATE.
>> AND ONE OF--THAT WAS ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT THINGS,
TO BE ON TIME, AND YOU'RE
DISQUALIFIED FROM THE CHALLENGE.
>> JUST KIND OF SUCKED.
BUT I JUST THINK THINGS
WENT WRONG FOR US.
I THINK IT-- THE WHOLE SITUATION
WAS JUST TOO MUCH.
>> I DON'T CARE THAT I LOST IT.
I'M ANNOYED THAT THERE WAS
NOTHING I COULD DO ABOUT IT.
>> I HAVE RECEIVED ALL THE
POINTS FROM THEIR DESIGNERS.
>> MELROSE,
OUR DESIGNERS SAID THAT
YOU ARE THE MOST FRIENDLY,
BUT, UH, YOUR RUNWAY WALK
IS INCONSISTENT,
AND YOU NEED TO PRACTICE MORE
IN FRONT OF A MIRROR.
FOR CARIDEE,
DESIGNERS SAID THAT WITH A
LITTLE PRACTICE,
THEY FELT YOU COULD WALK
THE HAUTE COUTURE RUNWAYS.
BUT YOU HAVE TO WORK ON
YOUR, UH, NATURAL LOOK.
SO WEAR A LITTLE BIT LESS MAKEUP
AND HAVE A NATURAL LOOK.
AND FOR EUGENA,
OUR DESIGNERS LOVE YOUR LOOK,
BUT THEY SAID THAT YOU HAVE TO
WORK A LITTLE BIT MORE
ON YOUR PERSONALITY.
THE MODEL THAT IMPRESSED
THE DESIGNERS THE MOST WAS...
MELROSE.
>> YAY!
>> YAY.
>> THANK YOU.
>> CONGRATULATIONS. COME HERE.
>> I WON. WHOO-HOO!
>> NOW PLEASE CHOOSE A FRIEND.
>> CARI.
>> OH, WOW. COOL. THANK YOU.
>> OKAY.
>> HEY, HEY.
>> NOW SINCE YOU WON THE,
UH, CHALLENGE,
THE PRIZE IS THAT YOU'RE GONNA
BE TREATED TONIGHT
LIKE A SUPERMODEL.
>> AAH!
>> AND YOU WILL BE TAKEN OUT
FOR DINNER TONIGHT
WITH YOUR PERSONAL CHEF.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> WOW. COOL.
>> SHE CAN WIN THE CHALLENGE.
I DON'T REALLY CARE.
>> BYE-BYE.
>> CIAO.
>> BYE.
(doorbell rings)
>> HELLO.
>> AAH!
>> OH, MY GOD. YAY!
I GOT TO HAVE DINNER CATERED
RIGHT TO MY HOUSE,
WHICH I GUESS,
IF I WAS A SUPERMODEL,
I WOULD BE DOING A LOT.
>> I CAN SMELL, LIKE,
THIS REALLY FISHY SMELL,
AND IT'S GROSSING ME OUT.
SO I'M GLAD THAT I DIDN'T EAT
ANYTHING OFF THAT GOURMET MENU.
>> CHEERS TO BEING BLOND,
SEXY AND YOUNG.
>> SALUD.
TO BEING BLOND, SEXY, YOUNG...
>> AND A SUPERMODEL.
I DO NOT WANT TO GO BACK
TO FARGO! (laughs)
OH, TYRA MAIL!
>> OKAY.
>> "DON'T LET THE PHOTOGRAPHER
BULLY YOU.
LOVE, TYRA."
>> BULL RIDING!
>> AAH!
>> WE'RE GOING TO THE BULL RING!
>> I'M HOPING THAT
IT'S A MECHANICAL BULL.
I DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH THE BULL,
AS LONG AS IT'S FAKE.
♪ ♪ ♪
>> I WALK INTO THE COLISEUM
NOT KNOWING WHAT TO EXPECT,
BUT KNOWING IT'S GONNA HAVE
SOMETHING TO DO WITH A BULL.
WE'RE IN BARCELONA.
OF COURSE
THERE'S GOTTA BE A BULL.
IT'S LIKE, YOU KNOW,
BEING IN NEW YORK
AND... EATING CHEESECAKE.
>> OH!
>> WOW.
>> MR. JAY DOESN'T LOOK
LIKE A MATADOR AT ALL.
HE LOOKS LIKE...
MR. JAY IN A MATADOR COSTUME.
>> OH, GOSH.
>> DON'T I DESERVE A LITTLE MORE
FOR PUTTING THIS ON...
>> WHOO!
>> THIS MORNING?
>> WELCOME TO MONUMENTAL.
THIS IS ONE OF THE LAST
REMAINING
ACTIVE BULLFIGHTING ARENAS.
SO THIS IS JUST THE
PERFECT SETTING
TO DO YOUR PHOTO SHOOT TODAY.
BUT THE LITTLE CATCH IS,
TODAY YOU GIRLS ARE GONNA BE
SHOOTING WITH A REAL BIG BULLY.
>> AAH!
(spaghetti western music
playing)
(whip cracks)
>> TORO!
>> OH!
>> YEAH!
>> HI, GUYS.
>> HE'S TAKING OUR PICTURES!
YAY!
>> OW!
>> I'M VERY HAPPY THAT NIGEL'S
GONNA BE OUR PHOTOGRAPHER.
AT THE SAME TIME,IT MAKES ME
VERY, VERY NERVOUS,
BECAUSE HE'S A JUDGE,
AND HE HAS A LOT OF SAY,
AND THERE'S A LOT TO IMPRESS.
>> WE DECIDED, YOU KNOW, WITH
THE SHOT,
WE CAN'T JUST HAVE YOU IN
WARDROBE IN A CAPE.
WE NEED A LITTLE SOMETHING ELSE.
SO YOU GIRLS ARE GONNA BE
SHOOTING WITH A BULL.
>> OH, GOD.
>> HEY!
>> (snorts)
>> LET'S GO!
>> OH, MY GOD! AAH!
>> (grunting, snorting)
>> OH, MY GOD. OH. OH.
NOT GONNA LIE--I GOT SCARED.
THIS THING COULD KILL ME.
(bull snorts)
>> HEY! HEY!
>> TODAY WE'RE DOING
A PHOTO SHOOT WITH A BULL,
AND I FEEL A LITTLE BIT
NERVOUS ABOUT IT.
I'M KIND OF SCARED.
(bull roaring)
>> OH, MY GOD.
DUDE, THAT GUY LOOKED AFRAID,
OKAY?
NOW I'M FREAKING OUT
A LITTLE BIT 'CAUSE NIGEL
IS OUR PHOTOGRAPHER TODAY.
IT'S INTIMIDATING BEING SHOT BY,
YOU KNOW, A JUDGE.
>> OH!
I CAN'T BELIEVE SHE SAID THAT.
>> CARIDEE MESSED UP.
THAT'S NOT A GOOD WAY TO START
THE DAY,
BECAUSE THAT'S ONE KEY THING
THAT TYRA'S LOOKING FOR--
A GIRL WHO CAN WORK IN THIS
BUSINESS
AND BE RESPECTFUL.
♪ ♪ ♪
>> WE'RE ALMOST GETTING
READY TO SHOOT,
BUT I WANTED TO TALK TO YOU
ABOUT SOMETHING WHILE NIGEL WAS
INSIDE
PREPPING FOR YOUR SHOOT.
CARIDEE MADE A STATEMENT
ABOUT NIGEL...
HOPEFULLY HE PULLED THAT
STICK OUT OF HIS ASS
SINCE LAST JUDGING,
AND THAT IS NOT A COMMENT
YOU MAKE TO A JUDGE.
THAT IS NOT A COMMENT
YOU MAKE TO A PHOTOGRAPHER,
SOMEBODY WHO IN THE FUTURE
COULD POSSIBLY HIRE YOU.
SO I WANT YOU GUYS TO REALIZE
YOU NEED TO GIVE HIM
SOME RESPECT, BECAUSE
HE'S NOT ONLY
SHOOTING YOU IN A VERY DIFFICULT
AND DANGEROUS SITUATION,
BUT HE'S REALLY THERE
TO DECIDE YOUR FATE AS A MODEL.
SO I MAKE THAT CLEAR?
I'M GONNA CHECK ON WHERE
WE'RE AT,
AND THEN I'M GONNA PULL THE
FIRST COUPLE OF GIRLS OUT.
IT WASN'T ANYTHING TO BE MEAN.
IT WAS TOTALLY--
THAT'S JUST MY HUMOR.
ONCE IT WAS BROUGHT TO
MY ATTENTION,
IT DID MAKE ME WORRY,
SO I'M LIKE,
OH, I DON'T WANNA UPSET A JUDGE.
IF I COULD TAKE IT BACK,
I WOULD.
>> GIRL, THOSE EARRINGS
ARE SUCK!
>> DUDE, I MEAN, YOU TOLD HIM TO
PULL THE THING OUT OF HIS ASS.
I THINK THAT CARI'S WORRIED
BECAUSE SHE
MADE A COMMENT TO NIGEL,
JOKING AROUND.
BETTER TO HAVE HIM ON YOUR SIDE
THAN AGAINST YOU,
THAT'S FOR SURE.
>> I DID BAD AT THE CHALLENGE.
I DIDN'T MAKE IT BACK
TILL A HALF AN HOUR AFTER
WE WERE SUPPOSED TO BE THERE.
THIS WEEK HAS BEEN REALLY SHAKY,
SO I'M--I'M KIND OF NERVOUS.
>> IF YOU HEAR THE HANDLERS
YELL "RUN,"
IT'S NOT MEANT TO PANIC YOU.
IT'S SO THAT YOU UNDERSTAND
THAT'S YOUR CUE TO GO AROUND
THE WALL.
OKAY?
>> (chuckles) ALL RIGHT.
>> COOL.
(bull snorts)
>> SO, AMANDA,
YOU'RE GONNA SIT HERE WITH ME
AND EUGENA, YOU'RE GONNA
GO OUT THERE FIRST.
>> I WAS FIRST. AND IF
THIS BULL COMES AT ME,
I'M RUNNING.
I'M NOT THINKING TWICE ABOUT IT.
FORGET THE PHOTO SHOOT,
'CAUSE I'M NOT TRYING
TO GET BUCKED BY NO BULL.
>> HEY, EUGENA, HOLD THAT STICK
LIKE A MATADOR'S CAPE.
I'M GONNA BE ADDING IT
TO YOUR PHOTO LATER.
>> NOW, EUGENA, YOU'RE GONNA
TWIST TOWARDS ME, PLEASE.
THIS IS YOUR MOMENT,
SO DON'T FREEZE UP ON ME NOW.
HOLD IT.
(bull snorts)
>> I JUST REALLY WANTED
TO GET INTO CHARACTER AND TRY
NOT TO BE SCARED OF THE BULL.
(bull snorts)
>> I'M GLAD THAT YOU'RE
TAKING IT THERE,
YOU'RE TAKING THE RISK NOW.
THIS IS WHEN IT BECOMES
MODELING FOR REAL.
THIS IS, LIKE, THE FIRST TIME
I'VE SEEN A TRUE MODEL
IN EUGENA.
>> TO EUGENA'S CREDIT,
SHE USED HER FEAR,
AND I LOVE THAT,
BECAUSE THAT SHOWS
THAT SHE'S A PROFESSIONAL MODEL.
>> EVEN THOUGH MY LIFE
IS LITERALLY
IN THE BULL'S HANDS,
I THINK I MIGHT'VE BEEN
A LITTLE MORE NERVOUS
WORKING WITH NIGEL 'CAUSE
NIGEL HAS A LOT MORE INFLUENCE
OVER MY--MY LIFE THAN THE BULL.
>> YOUR BODY'S SO SLIM
YOU GOTTA CREATE MORE ANGLES.
OKAY, CHANGE IT UP.
PULL YOUR LEGS TOGETHER
AND START AGAIN.
(bull snorts)
>> HEY, RUN.
>> (chuckles)
YOUR HEART WAS POUNDING
AND IT WAS SCARY.
>> I'M TRYING TO MAKE
FASHION HISTORY HERE.
>> DO YOU NEED A SECOND, AMANDA?
I WANT TO BE POSITIVE,
BUT IT'S JUST--
IT'S LOOKING VERY DISCONNECTED.
>> AMANDA DISAPPOINTED ME.
SHE FELT AWKWARD,
AND IT SEEMED LIKE ONE HALF
OF HER BODY WAS MODELING
AND THE OTHER HALF WASN'T.
SHE NEEDS TO GET THE
WHOLE THING TOGETHER.
>> I DON'T--MICHELLE,
WHAT DO YOU WANT ME TO TELL YOU?
>> WHAT YOU DID WRONG.
>> MY FEET AND MY--MY--
MY BODY MOVEMENTS.
>> OKAY.
>> WHAT MORE DO YOU WANT?
LIKE, MICHELLE, WHATEVER.
YOU'RE ANNOYING.
YOU'RE TALKING TOO MUCH.
>> FIND THE LIGHT.
YOU'VE GOT ME ON MY KNEES.
(laughs) IT'S THE FIRST GIRL
I'VE CRAWLED ON THE GROUND FOR.
I WAS INSPIRED BY MICHELLE
'CAUSE SHE USED THE FEAR.
SHE MODELED.
I'VE GOT 20 FRAMES LEFT, OKAY?
SO THAT MEANS THAT IN THESE 20
FRAMES,
I WANT TO SEE YOU REALLY
GO FOR IT.
>> SO I'M KIND OF ACTUALLY UPSET
AT NIGEL AND JAY GOING INTO
THIS,
'CAUSE, UM, MY SISTER HAD GOTTEN
A REALLY BAD CRITIQUE,
SO I'M, LIKE, GOING IN
THERE LIKE, YOU KNOW,
I'M JUST GONNA DO THIS.
I DON'T EVEN CARE.
>> THAT'S INTERESTING.
THAT IS GENIUS.
MICHELLE SOLD ME IN THE
LAST 20 FRAMES.
SHE DID THINGS THAT CAME
MUCH MORE NATURALLY TO HER.
THEREFORE, SHE LOOKED
LIKE A MODEL.
>> THANK YOU.
I WANT ARROGANCE, PRIDE.
I WANT FEAR.
>> YOU'RE HOLDING
THAT--THAT CAPE
A LITTLE TOO DELICATELY.
THERE YOU GO.
MELROSE JUST WANTED TO
IMPRESS NIGEL
AND IMPRESS ME SO MUCH
THAT SHE WASN'T THINKING.
SHE WASN'T ENGAGING HERSELF
IN THE SHOOT AT ALL.
MELROSE WAS JUST
GIVING US POSES.
>> FOR ME TODAY, MELROSE
WASN'T A STAR.
AT THIS STAGE IN THE
COMPETITION,
OTHER GIRLS ARE ALL RISING.
♪ ♪ ♪
(bull snorts)
>> IT WAS ABSOLUTELY TERRIFYING.
I WAS VERY TERRIFIED.
IT'S REALLY FRUSTRATING
BECAUSE I JUST WANT
TO DO REALLY WELL FOR NIGEL.
>> RELAX THE LIPS A LITTLE BIT.
BREATHE.
DON'T FORGET TO BREATHE.
>> IT LOOKS LIKE A PINUP GIRL.
THROW YOUR HIPS FORWARD.
YOU ARE STICKING YOUR BUTT
OUT...
>> YEAH.
>> AND YOU'RE DOING THIS
AND IT'S LOOKING VERY, LIKE,
PORNO STAR.
>> THE WAY CARIDEE WAS MODELING
WAS SO OVER-THE-TOP.
IT WAS JUST TOO MUCH.
>> I'M SORRY IF I OFFENDED YOU.
I WAS TOTALLY JOKING.
>> JOKE OR NO JOKE...
IN THE REALITY OF THE WORLD,
YOU HAVE TO BE CAREFUL.
YOU KNOW ME, BUT YOU
DON'T KNOW ME.
>> MM-HMM.
>> IF YOU SAY THINGS
THAT YOU REGRET, YOU KNOW,
YOU PUT YOURSELF IN A POSITION
YOU DON'T NEED TO BE IN.
>> RIGHT.
>> CARIDEE CLEARLY OFFENDING
NIGEL
LET THAT GET TO HER.
SHE KNEW SHE DID A POOR JOB.
>> WAS IT HORRIBLE?
I TRIED TO PUT MYSELF
IN THAT SPOT WHERE THE CHANCES
OF ME BEING ELIMINATED
WAS, LIKE, SLIM TO NONE,
AND NOW IT'S, LIKE,
A REALLY BIG CHANCE.
>> THAT'S A WRAP ON THE
BULL SHOOT.
(bull roars)
>> TYRA MAIL!
"TOMORROW YOU WILL MEET
WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY FOUR WILL CONTINUE ON
IN HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
LOVE, TYRA."
PANEL THIS WEEK WILL BE
PROBABLY THE WORST PANEL
I WILL EXPERIENCE,
'CAUSE I DID NOT DO WELL,
AND THEY WILL PROBABLY BE
HARSH ON ME.
>> I THINK AMANDA'S IN
TROUBLE THIS WEEK.
I THINK CARIDEE COULD BE
IN TROUBLE AGAIN THIS WEEK.
>> WHOA.
HOPEFULLY, MY COMMENT
ABOUT NIGEL
IS NOT GONNA PROHIBIT ME
FROM MOVING ON IN THIS
COMPETITION.
>> I WANT TO TAKE A NAP!
>> I NEVER EVER IN MY LIFE
ENVISIONED MYSELF
BEING THIS CLOSE TO BEING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
I WANT IT, BUT, LIKE,
I DON'T KNOW IF I HAVE IT.
>> UNACCEPTABLE!
BASED ON MY SISTER'S PERFORMANCE
AT THE PHOTO SHOOT,
I THINK SHE HAS A GOOD CHANCE
OF STAYING THIS WEEK, SO...
THAT MAKES ME WORRY FOR ME.
HA!
♪ ♪ ♪
>> HELLO, LADIES.
>> HI!
>> FIVE LEFT.
WELL, WELCOME TO THE
JUDGING ROOM.
YOU GUYS KNOW ABOUT OUR
FABULOUS PRIZES, DON'T YOU?
THE FIRST IS A CONTRACT
WITH ONE OF THE TOP
MODELING AGENCIES IN THE WORLD,
ELITE MODEL MANAGEMENT...
A COVER AND A 6-PAGE SPREAD
IN "SEVENTEEN" MAGAZINE...
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT WITH...
>> COVERGIRL!
>> HOLLA!
NOW IT'S TIME FOR ME TO
INTRODUCE YOU TO THE JUDGES.
THE FIRST IS THE NOTED FASHION
PHOTOGRAPHER MR. NIGEL BARKER...
RUNWAY DIVA COACH EXTRAORDINAIRE
WHO IS LITERALLY TAKING THE BULL
BY THE HORNS TODAY...
>> OH!
>> MISS J. ALEXANDER...
FASHION ICON AND LIVING
LEGEND TWIGGY,
AND OUR GUEST JUDGE IS PANCHO
SAULA, WHO YOU MET,
AND HE IS THE DIRECTOR OF ELITE
HERE IN BARCELONA.
ALL RIGHT, SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR YOUR JUDGING TEST,
AND MR. BARKER WILL
ADMINISTER IT.
>> OKAY, LADIES, WHAT I'D LIKE
YOU TO DO NOW
IS ONE AT A TIME FACE
THE JUDGES.
TELL US WHO YOU THINK
HAS THE MOST POTENTIAL,
AND WHO YOU THINK HAS
THE LEAST POTENTIAL,
TO BE AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
MELROSE.
>> I THINK THE MOST POTENTIAL
IN THIS ROOM
FOR AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL
LIES IN ME,
AND THAT'S BECAUSE I'M
DETERMINED AND I WANT THIS.
AND I THINK THAT THE LEAST
POTENTIAL IN THIS ROOM
LIES IN...
EUGENA.
I DON'T HEAR HER SAY
THAT SHE WANTS IT.
I DON'T HEAR ANYTHING,
AND IT'S SCARY TO HEAR NOTHING.
>> EUGENA.
>> UM, ACTUALLY I THINK, UM,
I HAVE THE MOST POTENTIAL
TO BE AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,
AND THAT'S BECAUSE, FOR ME,
IT'S BEEN A DIFFERENT STRUGGLE.
LIKE, I DIDN'T START OFF
AT THE TOP AT ALL.
I THINK THIS COMPETITION IS...
MORE ABOUT THE JOURNEY
TO GET TO THE TOP.
I THINK THE ONE THAT HAS
THE LEAST POTENTIAL...
AMANDA,
JUST BECAUSE IN THIS INDUSTRY
YOU CAN'T SECOND-GUESS YOURSELF.
>> CARIDEE.
>> OF COURSE I'M GONNA
PICK MYSELF
FOR MOST WANTING TO WIN
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
I SAY THAT BECAUSE I HAVE A
REALLY BIG PASSION
FOR THIS INDUSTRY.
I THINK THE PERSON WHO IS THE
LEAST CAPABLE--
I WOULD SAY AMANDA,
JUST BECAUSE I DON'T FEEL THAT
BEAMING FROM HER.
IF I'M GONNA LOSE, I WANT TO
LOSE TO SOMEONE WHO WANTS THIS
JUST AS BAD AS I DO.
>> AMANDA.
>> WHO I THINK HAS THE MOST
POTENTIAL EXCLUDING MYSELF,
'CAUSE I FEEL NO NEED TO TALK
ABOUT MYSELF,
'CAUSE I DO THINK I HAVE A LOT
OF POTENTIAL--
I THINK THE PERSON WITH THE MOST
POTENTIAL IS PROBABLY EUGENA,
BUT I DON'T KNOW IF SHE'S
USING IT.
PERSON I THINK WITH THE LEAST
POTENTIAL
WOULD PROBABLY BE CARIDEE.
HER LOOK IS JUST A LITTLE BIT,
UH, COUNTRY GIRL, AND, LIKE,
SHE DOES HAVE THE STRONG
FEATURES AND EVERYTHING,
BUT I FEEL LIKE I'VE
SEEN THEM BEFORE.
>> MICHELLE.
>> FOR THE STRONGEST,
I AM NOT GONNA GO WITH MYSELF,
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK I'M THE
STRONGEST IN THIS COMPETITION.
I WOULD PROBABLY PICK CARIDEE.
SHE DOES HAVE THAT
BUBBLY PERSONALITY.
I DON'T KNOW WHO TO PICK
FOR THE WEAKNESS BECAUSE...
(inhales sharply) SOMETIMES
I FEEL LIKE I HAVE THE WEAKNESS
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW WHAT I
WANT,
AND I'VE NEVER KNOWN WHAT
I WANT, BUT, LIKE,
I SEE OTHER GIRLS, LIKE--LIKE,
THEY WANT THIS SO BADLY.
LIKE WHEN BROOKE WAS LEAVING,
I FELT TERRIBLE BECAUSE
SHE WANTED THIS SO BADLY,
AND, LIKE, I DON'T KNOW
IF I-I COULD HAVE THE
ENERGY AND THE PASSION
THAT CARIDEE AND MELROSE HAVE.
IT'S FUNNY, WHEN I'M
IN PHOTO SHOOTS
AND I TRY, LIKE, THEY'RE LIKE,
"OH, YEAH, YOU KNOW,
YOU'RE POSING TOO MUCH."
BUT WHEN I JUST SIT THERE
AND GO LIKE THIS,
IT'S A PERFECT SHOT.
LIKE, WHEN I GET IN
FRONT OF THE CAMERA,
IT'S JUST NATURAL.
I DON'T KNOW HOW TO
BE SUPER CONFIDENT.
ALL RIGHT, SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR YOUR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS,
AND AFTER THAT,
THE JUDGES WILL DELIBERATE,
AND WE WILL DETERMINE
WHICH ONE OF YOU WILL BE
ELIMINATED.
SO WHO WAS FIRST? MELROSE.
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT.
THERE WAS A LITTLE DANGER
INVOLVED.
MR. NIGEL BARKER DID THE
PHOTOGRAPHY THAT I HAVE TO SAY
IS ABSOLUTELY STUNNING,
AND THERE WAS A LOT
OF ARTISTIC DIGITAL WORK
THAT NIGEL AND THE TEAM DID
TO CREATE THIS PHOTO,
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
I THINK IT'S STUNNING.
>> MELROSE, YOU HAD
A LOT OF ENERGY.
YOU WERE A GOOD MODEL.
THE THING ABOUT YOU, THOUGH,
IS THAT IT FELT A LITTLE TOO
REHEARSED.
WHAT YOU'VE GOT TO DO
IS BE NATURAL.
>> IT LOOKS VERY 1940s.
IT'S EXTRAORDINARY.
I HAVEN'T SEEN YOU
LOOK LIKE THAT.
>> MELROSE, YOU WERE THE
CHALLENGE WINNER AT THE GO SEES.
YOU SAW THE MOST CLIENTS
BUT ALSO YOUR SCORE WITH
THE CLIENTS WAS REALLY HIGH,
SO THAT'S A GOOD THING.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> WELL DONE, WELL DONE.
>> THANK YOU!
>> ALL RIGHT, EUGENA,
I LOVED THE FACT THAT
YOU TALKED ABOUT A JOURNEY.
AGAIN, IT'S A HUSTLE,
BECAUSE YOU KNOW THAT
YOUR PICTURES AREN'T AS STRONG
IN THE BEGINNING OF THIS
COMPETITION
AND THAT YOU'VE IMPROVED,
SO WHEN YOU SPOKE ABOUT
A JOURNEY, I WAS IMPRESSED
WITH THAT.
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> (chuckles) THAT IS A
GREAT PHOTOGRAPH.
>> EUGENA, YOU TOOK RISKS.
YOU HAD FUN WITH IT.
YOU WERE A PLEASURE
TO WORK WITH.
>> I WAS LOOKING AT IT LIKE,
WHO IS THIS GIRL?
WHY ALL OF A SUDDEN DOES SHE
HAVE PASSION IN HER EYES
IN ALMOST EVERY SINGLE FRAME?
>> WHY ARE Y'ALL GIVING HER
CREDIT FOR MY PICTURE?
(laughter)
>> THAT KIND OF LOOKS
LIKE ME UP THERE.
I'M--THAT LOOKS KIND OF LIKE,
THAT'S FIERCE, DARLING!
THAT LOOKS LIKE ME.
>> I THINK I'M VERY GOOD AT WHAT
I DO, AND I KNOW HOW TO MODEL...
>> YOU CAN'T DO THAT.
>> AND TWIST AND TURN AND
DO ALL KINDS OF STUFF,
BUT I CAN'T DO THAT.
>> CAN'T DO THAT.
>> I CAN'T DO THAT...
>> MNH-MNH.
>> UNLESS I'M GONNA
END UP IN THE HOSPITAL.
>> (laughs)
>> UP NEXT IS MICHELLE.
YOU GUYS WENT ON GO
SEES THIS WEEK.
YOU HAD THE STRONGEST PORTFOLIO,
AND I FIND THAT SO SAD,
BECAUSE YOU DON'T KNOW
YOUR OWN STRENGTH.
>> SOMETIMES I FEEL LIKE
I HAVE THE WEAKNESS BECAUSE
I DON'T KNOW WHAT I WANT.
>> YOU JUST HAVE A NATURAL
TALENT, AND YOU NEED
TO JUST ACCEPT, "I'M DOPE..."
>> (laughs)
>> "I DON'T KNOW WHY, BUT I AM."
AND HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> I WANTED TO SAY THAT
I LOVE YOUR FACE.
I THINK THAT YOU ARE THE MOST
INTERESTING IMAGE-WISE MODEL
IN THE COMPETITION.
>> MICHELLE, YOU WERE A
SURPRISE FOR ME.
IT'S ONE OF THOSE SITUATIONS
WHERE YOU DIDN'T KNOW REALLY
WHAT YOU WERE DOING,
BUT YOU DID IT WELL.
IF ONLY YOU COULD HAVE
AN OUT-OF-BODY EXPERIENCE
AND HAVE A LOOK AT YOURSELF.
>> SHE CAN TAKE A LOOK
AT HERSELF.
JUST LOOK AT HER PICTURES.
SHE CAN HAVE THE EXPERIENCE.
>> BUT YOU KNOW WHAT,
SHE DOESN'T LISTEN TO US,
DOES SHE?
'CAUSE WE'VE ALL TOLD HER
HOW GOOD SHE IS, BUT YOU STILL
SAY YOU DON'T KNOW WHY--
YOU JUST TOLD US YOU HAD THE
LEAST POTENTIAL.
>> YOU TOOK RISKS IN
THIS PHOTO SHOOT,
AND YOU GOTTA KNOW THAT
YOU'RE GOOD.
IT'S GONNA TAKE SOME TIME.
IT'S NOT OVERNIGHT, BUT IT'S A
JOURNEY,
AS EUGENA SAYS.
AMANDA.
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT,
AND HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> HER CLOSE-UP IS ABSOLUTELY
GORGEOUS.
>> VERY DRAMATIC.
>> THE CAMERA DOES LOVE YOU.
CAN YOU SEE THAT?
>> YEAH!
>> (laughs) YEAH!
>> YOU HAVE A GREAT LOOK.
WHAT YOU HAVE TO WORK WITH
IS UNDERSTANDING YOUR
TOP HALF OF YOUR BODY
AND YOUR BOTTOM HALF
OF YOUR BODY.
YOU SEEM TO BE WORKING
IN TWO DIFFERENT WAYS.
>> YEAH, AND GOING
THROUGH YOUR FILM,
THERE'D BE A BEAUTIFUL SHOT,
BUT THERE WAS AN AWKWARD
SECOND-GUESSING THING THAT I
THINK EUGENA SPOKE OF.
WHEN I PHOTOGRAPHED YOU,
YOU WERE SECOND-GUESSING
YOURSELF.
YOU'D POSE AND GO...
>> BOTTOM LINE IS, YOU'VE GOT A
GREAT EDITORIAL LINES--
BOTH YOU AND YOUR SISTER--
BUT WHETHER YOU'RE ACTUALLY
CAPABLE OF DOING IT AS WELL AS
YOUR SISTER, THAT'S ANOTHER
THING.
>> OKAY.
>> UP NEXT IS CARIDEE.
>> I WANTED TO SAY THIS--
"I WANT TO TAKE THE TIME OUT
TO SAY THANK YOU.
I CAN NEVER SHOW MY GRATITUDE
ENOUGH.
TYRA, YOUR HEART HAS ALLOWED ME
TO MAKE MY DREAMS COME TRUE.
I'M SORRY IF I DISAPPOINTED
OR DISRESPECTED ANY OF YOU.
I HOPE YOU ALLOW ME TO CARRY ON.
THERE'S NOTHING MORE THAT I WANT
TO DO THAN REPRESENT ALL OF YOU
IN A GOOD, RESPECTABLE, CLASSY,
FUN, RESPONSIBLE WAY."
>> I DO APPRECIATE YOU TAKING
THE TIME TO WRITE A LETTER
ABOUT YOUR MISTAKE WITH NIGEL,
BECAUSE I WAS INFORMED THAT
YOU SAID SOMETHING THAT WAS RUDE
AND WAY-TOO CROSSING THE LINE.
>> YEAH.
>> APOLOGY IS ACCEPTED,
BUT THE REASON WHY
WE BRING THIS UP IS THAT WE ARE
THE JUDGES, WE ARE
PHOTOGRAPHERS, WE ARE CLIENTS...
>> YEAH.
>> AND WE DON'T WANT SOMEONE
GOING OUT, REPRESENTING
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,"
COVERGIRL AND ELITE MODEL
MANAGEMENT
WHO DOESN'T ACT WITH CLASS,
DIGNITY AND RESPECT.
>> SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT,
AND HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
I SEE BEAUTIFUL PHOTOGRAPHY
BUT NOT STRONG MODEL.
>> HOW WAS IT FOR YOU?
>> IT WAS GOOD, IT WAS FUN,
BUT IT WAS INTIMIDATING.
SORRY, I'M JUST SO...
BEING AT THE END OF THIS
COM--OF THIS COMPETITION,
I'M TRYING TOO HARD.
YOU KNOW, I'M OVERTHINKING IT.
I'M TRYING SO HARD
IT'S RUINING ME, YOU KNOW?
>> I FELT YOU FELL WAY
BACKWARDS WHEN I WAS
GOING THROUGH YOUR FILM.
IT WAS LIKE PINUP.
IT REALLY WAS, LIKE...
I CALLED IT "HOOCHIE."
>> WHEN WE TALKED ABOUT THE
BODY SHAPE AND ELEGANCE,
I OFTEN FIND WITH YOU THAT
YOU ACT LIKE YOU'RE LISTENING,
BUT YOU'RE NOT REALLY.
>> ALL RIGHT, SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR THE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE,
AND WHEN I CALL YOU BACK,
I'LL ANNOUNCE WHICH ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED.
♪ ♪ ♪
>> NOW IT'S TIME TO MAKE A
DECISION. WHO'S GOING HOME?
AMANDA.
>> IT'S NOT MY FAVORITE
PHOTOGRAPH OF AMANDA,
APART FROM THE WAIST UP,
BUT I THINK SHE'S GOT
SOMETHING RATHER SPECIAL,
AND I'D LIKE TO KEEP HER IN.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT THOUGH, TWIGGY?
WAIST-UP MODELING ISN'T
GONNA CUT IT.
AMANDA HAS THE CONFIDENCE,
AND MICHELLE DOESN'T.
>> MICHELLE DOESN'T WANT
TO BE HERE, THOUGH.
SHE TOLD US THAT TODAY.
>> THE PROBLEM IS, IS THAT I
DON'T THINK AMANDA
ACTUALLY KNOWS HOW TO MODEL.
MICHELLE IS A NATURAL.
>> GREAT.
>> BUT SHE'S--
>> SO ONE GIRL'S A NATURAL
AND THE OTHER ISN'T.
ONE'S CONFIDENT, THE OTHER
ISN'T.
>> WELL, THAT'S YOUR OPINION.
IT'S NOT MY OPINION.
>> YEAH.
>> I THINK AMANDA--I THINK
SHE HAS LOTS OF POTENTIAL.
>> MICHELLE.
>> MICHELLE IS THE MOST
INTERESTING FOR ME FROM ALL OF
THEM.
THE ONES THAT BECOME BIG MODELS
ARE THOSE THAT DON'T EVEN KNOW
THAT THEY CAN BECOME MODELS.
EVENTUALLY WITH THE TIME,
SHE WILL GET THE CONFIDENCE,
AND SHE WILL GO FOR IT.
>> BUT WITH MICHELLE, I THINK
WITH TIME
SHE'LL JUST PROBABLY
GET BORED WITH IT.
>> I DO WORRY ABOUT THE WAY
SHE TALKS AND PRESENTS HERSELF,
BUT THEN I LOOK AT THIS
PHOTOGRAPH.
IT'S A CONUNDRUM.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO
ABOUT MICHELLE.
>> I WONDER IF MICHELLE DOES
WANT THIS, BUT SHE KNOWS
HER SISTER WANTS IT MORE,
SO SHE'S GONNA SACRIFICE
HERSELF.
>> (gasps)
>> AH!
>> OOH!
>> I WONDER THAT.
CARIDEE.
>> SHE'S VERY SWEET, BUT
SHE SEEMS SAD TO ME.
>> I THINK THAT'S BECAUSE YOU'RE
WATCHING A MODEL FALL APART
IN FRONT OF YOUR EYES.
>> YEAH.
>> NO ONE'S EVER PULLED
OUT A LETTER.
A "TOP MODEL" FIRST.
>> CARIDEE, SHE WAS BUBBLY,
SHE WAS ALWAYS SMILING.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT IT
WENT TO HER HEAD,
I THINK, A LITTLE BIT.
SHE THOUGHT THAT SHE HAD
THE COMPETITION IN HER POCKET,
AND THEN SHE GOT SASSY,SHE GOT
COOL, AND SHE DIDN'T LISTEN.
>> THIS IS NOT A VERY
GOOD PHOTOGRAPH.
WELL, AGAIN, WHEN WE WENT IN
FOR THE CLOSE-UP,
I DID LOVE THE FACE.
>> CARIDEE'S FACE REALLY DIDN'T
CARRY
THAT KIND OF MAKEUP VERY WELL.
>> (deep voice) BUT WHY DID YOU
THINK SHE DIDN'T
CARRY THE MAKEUP THAT WELL?
>> WELL, SHE ENDED UP LOOKING A
LITTLE DRAG-ISH.
>> THAT'S WHAT I THOUGHT YOU
WERE GETTING AT. OKAY.
>> (laughs)
>> YEAH.
>> HEY!
>> MELROSE.
>> SHE WAS THE CHALLENGE WINNER
AT THE GO SEES.
SHE WANTS IT.
I THINK THIS IS A GREAT
PHOTOGRAPH OF HER,
AND SHE LOOKS DIFFERENT
IN EVERY SHOT WE SEE HER IN.
>> AND ALL THE GIRLS HATE HER
BECAUSE SHE WORKS SO HARD.
>> BUT WHAT MELROSE DOESN'T HAVE
FOR ME IS THAT SORT OF
INTANGIBLE THING THAT MAKES ME
EXCITED,
MAKES YOU WANT TO SHOOT HER.
>> LIKE MICHELLE.
>> EUGENA.
>> I DIDN'T LIKE EUGENA
BECAUSE SHE WAS SO SILENT.
NOT THAT SHE WAS SILENT
WITH WORDS.
SHE WAS SILENT IN PRESENCE
AS WELL.
>> MM-HMM.
>> WHEN SHE CAME ON SET,
THE SAME THING--
SHE WAS DEAD SILENT,AND
I THOUGHT, OH, GOODNESS,
HERE WE GO.
BUT ACTUALLY, SHE USED THAT FEAR
AND SHE HARNESSED IT.
>> MAYBE THE FEAR HELPED
GET A GREAT PICTURE.
>> I KNOW, BUT YOU CAN'T
BRING A BULL WITH YOU
EVERY TIME, LUV.
>> (laughs)
>> THAT IS NOT THAT GIRL
WITH THAT--REMEMBER
THE SECOND PHOTO SHOOT,
WHEN THE BIG CRAZY HAIR,
AND SHE JUST DID NOT
LOOK LIKE A MODEL.
THIS IS LIKE MORE THAN A MODEL.
THIS IS LIKE A MODEL/ACROBAT...
>> .../MISS J.
>> FIVE OF YOU STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE FOUR PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS, AND THESE
PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE FOUR OF YOU THAT WILL
STILL BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME THAT I'M
GOING TO CALL...
EUGENA.
MISS LADY'S COME A LONG WAY!
AND AS YOU SAID, IT'S ABOUT
THE JOURNEY,
AND WHAT YOU'RE EXPERIENCING
IS A TRUE JOURNEY.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
MELROSE.
ONE THING YOU HAVE OVER
ALL OF THESE GIRLS IN HERE
IS A KNOWLEDGE OF FASHION.
THIS COMPETITION'S
GETTING STIFF.
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT A
PRETTY PICTURE ANYMORE.
IT'S ABOUT SO MUCH MORE.
KEEP UP THE GOOD WORK.
>> (whispers) THANK YOU.
>> THE NEXT NAME THAT
I'M GOING TO CALL...
CARIDEE.
>> (crying)
>> IT'S SO NOT WORTH IT, IS IT?
>> UNH-UNH.
>> TO BE QUICK-MOUTHED AND...
>> CHEEKY, 'CAUSE YOU
SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
AND IN THE REAL WORLD OF
MODELING,
THERE'S NO SECOND CHANCES.
>> MNH-MNH.
>> THEY'RE LIKE,
"SHE INSULTED ME.
CANCEL HER FOR MY FASHION SHOW.
SEND HER HOME RIGHT NOW."
SO YOU LEARNED A LESSON.
>> (laughs) YES.
>> AND YOU HAVE A MAN BEHIND ME
TO THANK FOR FORGIVING YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> WILL AMANDA AND MICHELLE
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO IN MY
HANDS.
I WILL ONLY CALL ONE NAME.
AND THE GIRL THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY
RETURN TO THE HOUSE, PACK YOUR
BELONGINGS AND GO HOME.
BACK IN CASTING, I THOUGHT
THE TWO OF YOU
WOULD BE A PART OF THE
FINAL THREE,
BUT THAT'S NOT THE CASE,
AND I THINK YOU KNOW WHY
YOU BOTH STAND BEFORE ME.
ONE OF YOU HAS SUCH A NATURAL
TALENT, AND IT'S SO CRAZY
BECAUSE SOMETIMES IN THE
MODELING INDUSTRY,
THAT PERSON THAT IS SO GIFTED
DOESN'T HAVE A PASSION FOR IT.
IT JUST IS.
BUT THE JUDGES LOOK AT YOU
AND THEY SAY, DAMN!
SHE MIGHT NOT HAVE A PASSION
FOR THIS YET.
MAYBE SHE NEEDS TO STAND ON HER
OWN, NOT WITH HER SISTER.
AND THEN THERE'S YOU, THE GIRL
THAT HAS ALL THE DRIVE IN THE
WORLD.
BUT THE TALENT? WE DON'T KNOW.
JUST BECAUSE YOU WANT SOMETHING
AND JUST BECAUSE IT'S A DREAM,
IT DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEAN
THAT YOU'RE GREAT AT IT.
>> AMANDA.
IN THIS COMPETITION, PASSION
IS WAY MORE IMPORTANT
THAN BEAUTIFUL PICTURES.
♪ ♪ ♪
>> WE WANT THE WINNER OF
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
TO WANT IT, TO FEEL IT,
TO BREATHE IT, TO LOVE IT,
AND I KNOW THAT YOU DO.
AND YOU ARE YOUR WORST ENEMY,
SECOND-GUESSING,
WONDERING, "AM I GOOD ENOUGH?
IS THIS RIGHT? IS THAT RIGHT?"
(lowered voice) JUST GO.
JUST LET IT GO AND KNOW THAT
YOU'RE GOOD ENOUGH
AND YOU'RE TALENTED AND
YOU'RE BEAUTIFUL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> (normal voice) TRUST THAT.
>> OKAY.
>> M'KAY?
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> (mouths words)
>> (whispers) CONGRATULATIONS.
THANKS, MICHELLE.
>> (mouths words)
>> THANK YOU.
♪ ♪ ♪
>> (sniffling)
>> I KINDA SHOT MYSELF IN THE
FOOT TODAY,
BUT I DIDN'T WANT MY SISTER TO
LEAVE 'CAUSE THIS
IS ONE OF HER DREAMS, TOO.
MAYBE I WAS A DISTRACTION.
NOW THAT I'M GONE, I HOPE IT
GIVES HER MORE FOCUS.
I DON'T WANT HER TO EVER
SECOND-GUESS HERSELF.
SHE IS AMAZING. SHE'S MY SISTER.
I LOVE HER.
I GUESS I WAS HERE TO FIND
MYSELF,
AND I FOUND A LITTLE BIT OF
SOMETHING,
SO THAT WORKS FOR ME.
I'M 18. I'M SO YOUNG.
THERE'S SO MUCH MORE
LIFE TO LIVE.
I NEED TO JUST EMBRACE IT
INSTEAD OF JUST HIDING FROM IT.
♪ ♪ ♪